I was there I was there at the dawn of
the third age
this is an Interstellar News Network
Special Report two years after winning
the shadow War Captain John Sheridan
president of the interstellar Alliance
is leaving Babylon 5 for what many
expect to be the last time I don't need
an Interstellar Alliance you're my
universe still in I love you
a friend of mine once said the future is
all around us waiting in moments of
transition to be born in moments of
Revelation this is just such a moment
fire this baby up
oh something's wrong what kind of energy
does this facility use tachyons oh crap
where the hell am I yes I'm stuck in
time moving between timelines Universe
realities
the longer you stay out of your own
timeline the more you'll start sliding
in parallel worlds so how do I fix it
you have to get back to Babylon 5.
yeah
losing the shadow War wasn't your fault
wait we lost the war on the positive
side at least we have a good view of the
show
this is Babylon 5. we are under attack
do you know what a Last Stand is you
just joined one activate the struck
sequence destruct sequence are you
feeling
only in a mood that blows some stuff up
everything ends I'm Not Afraid bring it
John stay back happening again I'm
coming unstuck in time
[Music]
you look like someone in need of a
friend